okay I'm going to start by giving a
brief introduction to some common simple
models of distributed computing they'll
present a number of impossibilities alts
for different problems and different
distributed models to illustrate
different proof techniques so a
distributed system is a collection of
processes it can communicate by sending
and receiving messages amongst one
another or by performing operations on
shared objects in the first case we say
that we have a message passing system or
a model and in the second case we say
that we have a shared memory model
executions can be either finite or
infinite and an infinite executions can
describe the correct operation of an
algorithm such as an operating system
that isn't supposed to stop or can
describe a situation in which an
algorithm doesn't terminate because it's
incorrect in addition a model can be
synchronous or asynchronous the
synchronous systems processes take steps
at the same rate in such models an
execution is divided into rounds and in
each round each process takes one step
in which it receives messages from other
processes does local computation and
sends a message to two other processes
and the message is sent in one round are
received in the next round the
synchronous models can differ in the
number of messages a process can send
each round and whether all the messages
processes and around must be the same so
whether it's broadcast or point-to-point
communication a configuration describes
the system between consecutive rounds it
consists the state of every process at
the end of the preceding round and the
messages that are in transit okay it
also
basically what we preach edge of the
network we have to know which messages
were sent along the edge of the network
during the proceeding around in which
we'll receive during following around an
initial configuration describes the
system at the beginning of an execution
and each process is in an initial state
which includes its input and there are
no messages in transit okay so that's
that's what we have for a asynchronous
message passing system now we also have
asynchronous message passing systems and
their processes take steps in an
arbitrary order and from a theoretical
point of view this is determined by an
adversarial scheduler and an execution
here is a sequence of steps in each step
either one message is delivered or one
process receives messages that have been
delivered to it from other processes
this local computation and sends
messages to other processes messages can
take arbitrarily long to be delivered
these models can differ in the number of
messages that a process can send in any
round it send at any step or the number
it receives in any step and again when
it's sending multiple messages at one
step whether if they all have to be the
same or they can be different
in this model a configuration describes
the system between constant concepts
that describes the system between
consecutive steps of an execution again
but it consists of the state of every
process the messages that each process
is sent that have not yet been delivered
and the messages that have been
delivered to each process which has not
yet received so we can sort of think of
this link between this edge between
these two processes things get sense
they can put on the edge then they're
delivered and then they received it and
another step an initial configuration
describes a system at the beginning of
an execution
each processes is initial state which
includes its input and there are no
messages in transit the other model we
want to consider is asynchronous shared
memory we want to consider asynchronous
shared memory models again processes
take steps in an arbitrary order
determined by an adversarial scheduler
and an execution is just a sequence of
steps so these are very similar but the
communication is different in each step
one process performs an operation on a
shared object and does local computation
so in particular here we have a process
that may be writing to this object and
reading from that object each object has
a type which specifies the set of
possible values that can have its
initial value and the set of operations
that can be applied to it when a process
performs an operation on an object it
gets back a response the process updates
its state depending on the current state
and the response from the object the
operation might may also change the
value of the object and all of these
things occur atomically this means the
two operations don't overlap one example
of an object is a register the set of
possible values can be arbitrary but in
general we think about the integers and
are the natural numbers with initial
value 0 read returns the value of the
register and but doesn't change that its
value and write sets the value of the
register to the input value to the
parameter fee a write always just
returns ACK an acknowledgment another
example of an object is a compare and
swap object here we have one additional
value in our set which is a bottom which
is the initial value and this object
supports one operation which is called
casts and it takes two parameters in
addition to the name of the object U and
V and essentially what it does is it
compares the value of the the object R
and if it is equal to u the value of the
second parameter it changes the value of
r2 from u to V otherwise it leaves the
value of R unchanged in any case it
always returns the value of the object
even via Nautilus rebuttal these are
felt so though you and V your possible
values and you typically you and V is
not going to be bottom but yeah
certainly you can otherwise we're not
going to be able to change the state of
it at all okay now throughout this talk
I am NOT going to talk about and the
only what I'm talking about shared
memory I'm only going to consider
registers just to make things simple but
I just want you to know that there's
lots and lots of different types of
objects and there's a huge part of the
theory of distributed computing that
looks at understanding the relationships
between those so in a shared memory
system a configuration describes the
system between consecutive steps of an
execution it consists of the state of
every process and the value of every
shared object and again initial
configuration describes the system at
the beginning of an execution each
process is in its initial state which
includes its input and each shared
object has a predetermined initial value
its terminus system may also experience
faults ok the simplest is a crash fault
in which a process simply stops taking
steps before it finishes its task so
when a process is done and doesn't do
anything else we don't say it's crashed
but if it's in the middle of doing
something and doesn't take any more
steps ie the adversarial scheduler stops
scheduling it takes steps we say that
the process is crashed there are a whole
bunch of other kinds of faults that are
considered things like the worst of
visiting faults where a faulty process
can arbitrarily deviate from its it's
protocol there are things where there's
just faults in the communication system
where messages are lost or duplicated
reordered shared objects can not can
return the wrong value or can not
receive the value of this written that's
somehow misapplied the operation that's
applied to them can be wrong and we're
not going to include it consider any of
them when I sometimes I'll consider
models where there are no faults and
other times I'll consider the Philby
models where there are crash failures
but I for the purposes of this talk I'm
only gonna
restrict our attention to that
okay now there's not a sharp boundary
between distributed and parallel
computing okay the essential difference
really is the types of problems that are
considered in distributed computing each
process may have its own task to do or
something that it has to perform and
where is it and each process typically
has its own inputs in parallel computing
typically there's one task that's shared
by all processes and all inputs are
available to all processes for example
in the shared memory
okay so distributed computing typically
more processes make the tasks harder
okay because there's more contention or
conflict between the different processes
to to achieve what they need to get done
whereas in parallel computing more
processes make the task easier because
the work can be divided up amongst
different processes and if it somehow
having more processes problematic than
some of the processes you program them
so they just won't be taking any steps
and that's fine okay and typically in
parallel computation we don't think
about fault tolerance where that is
something that's pretty fundamental to
distributed computing
okay different usually in parallel using
your thinking it's like a specific
input/output that you're trying to keep
these words and distributed computing
it's just like you're trying to reach
some state sometimes yes sometimes no so
I mean like matrix multiplications
something typically one would do in
parallel computing and wouldn't be
considered a a distributive problem but
you may want to compute let's say Z you
you may have the underlying network that
you're given and you may want to compute
the diameter of the network so you're
still there may be something in that
case it's a particular task but one of
the differences there in a parallel
setting you might have that graph
presented to everybody or everybody has
some information about it
aspects of it are available to everybody
but in distributed computing you don't
sort of have your own look your local
knowledge of that and at the end every
process has to have the answer whereas
in parallel computing you might have all
it's important is that say one process
has the answer so those are it's really
the kinds of problems as we were looking
at but yeah other questions
so here are some of the main problems of
complexity theorists study about
distributed computation so what problems
can be solved in a given distributed
model okay and that really there is can
be quite a bit of difference between
synchronous models and asynchronous
models and if it can be solved how
efficiently can a particular problem be
solved in that model understanding what
makes certain problems hard to solve
and here we're often looking at
fundamental problems that are used as
building blocks in in many distributed
algorithms
another thing is because there's so many
different models we want to understand
how the parameters of the model affect
its computational power okay I'm not
expecting you to remember your 15
different models so I'll what I talk
about the models old each time I'm going
to give a lower bound I'll I'll tell you
which particular model we're looking at
and more generally what are the
relationships between the computational
power of different models
now most impossibility results in
distributed computing rely on lack of
knowledge about the system so at any
point in time the state of a process
including the values of its inputs and
local variables describes the knowledge
the process has about the system and to
solve them any distributed problems
processes need to learn information
about the states of other processes so
under solvability proof show that this
knowledge can't be obtained and lower
bound proofs show that this knowledge
cannot be obtained within limited
resources now initially processes lack
knowledge of inputs of other processes
and possibly some parameters of the
system for example they may not know the
number of processes they may not know
the names of the processes they may not
know the structure of the network okay
so those are things that would be
unknown an additional their additional
lack of knowledge can arise from a
synchrony because you don't know how the
adversarial scheduler has scheduled the
other processes and hence you know don't
know what even if you knew what their
state was at the beginning you wouldn't
know what it is later on and also the
problem can arise from false for the
rest of this hour I'll present results
book message passing models and after
the break I'll present some results
about shared memory models okay any
questions
okay so the first problem I want to
discuss this leader election okay so
here we want to have this out what is it
each each exactly one process who will
called the leader must output 1 and all
other processes motor must output 0 and
this particular problem there are no
inputs ok not necessarily no no so this
is it's a yes it's a simplified an
easier problem ok if you actually
require everybody to know who the leader
is that computationally it's much more
difficult yeah
specific yeah ok so the one I want to
look at a synchronous message passing
and in each round each process receives
a message from each of its neighbors in
the network and sends a message to each
of its neighbors and they can be
arbitrary arbitrarily different I'm not
going to assume any fault so we're not
going to look at that and but I'm going
to assume that the processes are
anonymous this means they don't have guy
IDs so they're all going to start in the
same initial state and run the same
program so we have some sort of a
network and that's what ever happened so
the first result that I want to talk
about is a very simple one which says
there's no deterministic algorithm for
leader election even if all processes
know the network is a cycle of size n ok
so it's a very very simple Network and
this is a very simple actually result
but you're just so sort of a warm up ok
so even in such a simple network it's
unsolvable but more complicated ones it
would be as well ok so the difficulty is
that there's no way to break initial
symmetry so initially all the processes
look at the intervals of one another
because in terms of the network
symmetric and their initial states are
symmetric so to obtain a contradiction
let's suppose there is an algorithm for
doing leader election ok then initially
they're all the processes are on there
saying they're in the same state and by
induction at the end of every round
every process must be in the same state
as every other process thus if one
process outputs one they all must output
1 and that contradicts the correction
correctness ok so that was easy good
however even so this is looking at
deterministic algorithms but if there's
randomized algorithms well in fact back
in the previous situation if we have a a
a cycle like this is the set up with
randomization it's easy game
what we have is every process randomly
chooses this value between 1 and N
squared and then they basically send
messages around trying to figure out
which was the largest value that any
process is chosen and then check to see
that that's unique ok so this is
possible to do with randomization and in
many cases what we have for many
problems there are situations where
deterministically the problems are
solvable and with randomization and
become solvable ok and so we'll see a
number of examples of that as we go
along ok so but in this particular
situation
there's no randomized algorithm for
leader election if they if processes
don't know the size of the cycle so even
if processes know that the network
there's a cycle but don't know its size
they can't solve leader election and in
fact ok
so in fact all they have to they don't
even have there can be some bounds on
that even if they don't know the size of
the the cycle to within a factor of 2
that's sufficient to I get this a
possibility result ok so to obtain a
contradiction suppose there is such an
algorithm and because of symmetry a
process can't tell if it's in a cycle of
size N or a cycle of size 2n ok
thus if there's an execution in a cycle
of size N where some process let's say
this top one here decides to output 1
then there's an execution in this this
larger cycle ok of size 2n in which both
this process and that process output 1
ok because they're going to be in the
same state
ok and this contradicts the correct
operation of the the algorithm yes
correct afraid you won't need to think
there's no there they need to be correct
always yes okay
typically when I'm looking at randomized
computation and distributed setting I
want correctness but I mean they have
some the randomization can allow
infinite executions with a zero
probability yes yes that's exactly right
yeah
you'll be to coffee service one cook so
here so here what these are just these
SS denote the state of the process okay
remember these are anonymous processes
okay so they don't have IDs so all we
can talk about is their states okay now
what is the state well they flip some
coins and now these they still keep
information in about the size of the
network but there's a problem in that
they can't they can't so this this
process and this process can end up
exactly well they know in this
particular our model is in which we have
things about steady state kinds of
things in this particular problem when I
talked about later election okay we have
the notion of output so exactly one
process myself but one and all other
processes not so good zero so at some
point they did perform an output
operation okay and that's what we mean
by the computation we're not worried
about this here we're just saying
whether it's solvable or not and so
we're not even worrying about any
resources because it's not solvable at
all that's right I mean there are
variants of this and but we're not
looking at that here these were supposed
to be just some easy things to get
people warmed up okay all right so the
problem was that we were dealing with
anonymous processes yes we know that the
length length of the cycle is either n
or 2n
no I think that this is the the same
proof went through no because what would
you would flip coins in the range you
know zero to I mean choose a number so
that you each process would choose a
number in the range 1 to N squared and
then you'd you want to see if the
problem is you let's say the highest
number okay which is it would be the
number of the leader you'd have to try
and figure out whether that occurred
once or occurred twice okay if it
occurred twice you can't tell did it go
around if you know the size of the
cycles and you can go all the way around
count to n and then say okay yeah cuz I
I've just passed it around in my value
came back and nobody else had that but
if you don't know if it's in or to in
then you could have one or two different
values he knows you know the cycle is
exactly a more exactly 2 n right
I think this you might be able to figure
out that there are n plus 1 distinct
elements at least by randomization
but it's equally right so you don't want
even a very small you know it so you
know it's exactly do it how do you know
maybe that's but what happens if this
cycle was of size N and then your head
then you're not gonna that's never gonna
happen and so then but this is one of
the problems with distributed computing
they're not only do we have you know
change the variety of inputs these
there's so many executions we have to
think about all of them so we do
randomized case you are
the number of steps like there's no
moment we're not well I mean it just it
makes the model stronger I'm stronger
and what I'm just saying is this is
unsolvable even if you don't have a
bound on the number of steps we're not
we're not dealing with that yeah all
right so what we want to do is look at
the the leader election problem where
we're getting away from the problem of
anonymous processes and we're going to
assume that every process is a distinct
ID okay and so otherwise but the other
difference we're gonna have is we're
gonna say that we're a lot of process
crashes so we're going to allow up to F
processes to crash so what that means is
the adversarial scheduler is allowed to
schedule things it's allowed to stop
scheduling up to F different processes
okay now we also have to be a ok we have
to be a little bit careful in the model
so when if a process since if an on
faulty process sends a message to
another non faulty process then
eventually that message has to be
delivered okay since the notion is if we
have two non faulty processes we're
assuming the link between them is also
non faulty okay so that what that is
really is a constraint on the
adversarial scheduler okay so we have
that set up in the model and and we we
we also have a slightly different
statement of the of the actual problem
okay so every non [ __ ] so instead of
having every process must output 0 1 we
have to say that every non faulty
process must output 0 1 because process
is false II never get steps so how can I
don't put anything ok and we also have a
another requirement the no process can
output 0 until the eventual leader the
process that's going to eventually
output 1 takes its first step ok we're
and the reason for that is because
enterprise if you just have processes
output zero and then the process and
then all the other processes crash you
may end up having no leader at all and
anyhow it's not a very interesting
situation what we're trying to model is
a situation its leader election is
basically used as a subroutine when you
want to have some process to do
something on behalf of the others yes
yeah
when when can the adversary decide when
to crash a process does it have to
decide the beginning before you know it
no I mean yeah I think it's you
typically just as it's going along
during the during the execution I can do
it earlier once okay all right so here
we have a again another fairly simple
result which says that there's no
algorithm for leader election and an
asynchronous message passing system
within processes if more than half the
processes can crash okay at least a
ceiling event or two of the processes
can crash and the way we do this is we
were basically to use something called a
partition argument okay
so again to obtain a contradiction
suppose there is such an algorithm and
what we're going to do is partition the
network into two parts each of size at
most F okay and since F is greater than
equal to ceiling event over to we can do
that okay
all right now let's see how the
adversary is going to perform okay so
what it's going to do is that the
adversary of scheduler is going to
deliver all messages feeding processes
in the same half of the partition okay
but it's going to delay the messages
that go from one part of the partition
to the other part so these things are
going to be delayed I mean they're not
unless the process is on one end or the
other crash it can't delay them forever
but in any case we'll have this okay now
let's look at the processes in the left
part okay so as far as they know all of
the processes in the right part may have
crashed before taking any steps because
the number of processes in here is it
most F so it's possible that that could
happen
so eventually okay if they waited long
enough they one of them has to open a
one and so that the other ones can
output zero okay similarly in the right
part okay these processes here as far as
they're concerned all the processes in
here may have crashed and so there must
be some process in here that will
eventually output one and so that the
other ones could output zero okay
now let's look at the situation after
these two processes have output one okay
then the adversary adversarial scheduler
is going to deliver all of these
messages okay
and lo and behold we have an incorrect
solution okay
even with randomization yeah that
doesn't affect anything okay so this
corrects this execution contradicts the
correctness of the algorithm okay so
those were all really easy ones where I
start to get into some that have a
little bit more meats in them now okay
so the next lower lower bound I'm gonna
I'm gonna actually present two lower
bound and this is gonna use a technique
called indistinguishability okay and
this is in fact indistinguishability in
fact is used as part of almost every
lower bound technique but I'm gonna just
give you some of the background
definitions here okay so we say that two
configurations C and C are
indistinguishable to suicide processes P
and we denote that with see this twiddle
P C Prime if each process and P has the
same state and C and in both
configurations and we see that two
executions starting from those
configurations are indistinguishable to
the set of processes which we denote in
a very similar way if the the starting
configurations of those executions are
indistinguishable to the processes in P
and H processes and P performs the state
steps in execution alpha as a dozen
alpha prime and those steps are
performed in the same order and so we
each process has the steps performing
the same order both oh you know they
maybe intervene differently and moreover
each process gets the same responses
from those steps so for example if it's
a shared memory model though they'll be
and they're doing reads they'll get the
same values back if they're getting
messages if in a message passing model
they'll have the same messages at the
same time they don't have the same
contents okay so that's so the that's
what we mean by in this
indistinguishable execution this as far
as they're concerned everything looks
the same
synchronous asynchronous whatever okay
this is just a general some messages may
have been sent but not yet received yeah
so when they're things are sent but not
just received what we have to worry
about is whether the executions are
accessing even in those different
configurations there may be different
messages and transit and so if the
algorithm if during that execution those
messages are accessed then we would the
executions would not be just would not
be indistinguishable okay now suppose
that alpha is a finite execution
starting from some configuration see
when you see alpha to denote the
configuration at the end of alpha
okay just and I'll be using that
notation not so much here but a lot
later on and there's a very simple
proposition so suppose that alpha and
alpha prime or finite executions
starting from configuration C and C
prime and they're indistinguishable
process processes then the resulting
configurations are indistinguishable to
that set of processes oh yeah there
should have been an alpha prime sorry
and we need C and C prime are yes so
that but if we go back to okay that's
part of alpha and alpha prime being
indistinguishable
all right so now I wanted to like to
give a natural fairly interesting lower
bound finally so here we have so now we
have we're looking at the same a
synchronous message passing system that
we were looking at before but now
remember the previous results said that
if sealing event over two processes can
crash then the problem is unsolvable
okay so now we're going to say okay well
we rolling an allow sealing event over
two minus one processes to crash okay so
we were not in that situation then the
claim is that any algorithm and an
asynchronous message passing system
within processes as omegas and squared
worst-case expected message complexity
so even if we're dealing with the
randomized algorithm essentially we have
to have lots and lots of messages in
order to do later election message to
process your total this is a this is a
total total number of messages as
percent okay all right so to obtain a
contradiction suppose there's such an
algorithm and the idea is that the
adversary the adversarial scheduler is
going to pick a set of floor event over
four processes and it's going to put
each one in a bubble so the the
scheduler is going to allocate steps in
a round-robin odd order to the processes
and that's not just sent to or from a
process in the bubble are gonna be
trapped in this bubble so basically a
message does it send it's never going to
be delivered and anything that you send
to it it's not going to be delivered as
well it's just going to be sort of
hanging there okay but all other
messages are going to be delivered
immediately as soon as they're set okay
and um the the Epis aerial scheduler is
going to release a process from its
bubble when its buffer contains at least
n over four messages okay so once it's
minh city contribute to our tour overall
some in a meaningful way will let it
continue
okay now teach process not in a bubble
this execution is indistinguishable to
an execution in which all processes
remains and bubbles have crashed okay so
I mean they're only eight over four of
them it's getting no communication from
them so as far as it's good the process
it's not in bubble is concerned you know
those ones have crashed and everything
else is going on okay
now let's look at a process in a bubble
so it's indistinguishable to an
execution in which the following
processes have crashed the other
processes in bubbles it's not the
processes which have sent a message to
p.i in the processes to which p i-- has
sent a message okay so that's a P I must
eventually leave its bubble will return
while it's still in a bubble okay
yeah so the point is that there at most
n over four processes and bubbles and
altogether there there's at most there's
less than annum for four processes and
the other two categories as well okay
now the claim is that no process P I can
return well it's still in a bubble okay
why well because all the steps might be
four might be before the steps of um all
the other processes in which case P I
would have to perform I would have to
output 1 return 1 but it might also be
the case to all the steps are after one
or more other processes of returned ok
in which case P I must return zero ok so
someone else might have already been
chosen as the leader that's every
process in a bubble must eventually
leave its bubble okay now there are n
over four processes initially in bubbles
and the processes released for its
bubble would in the buffer its buffer
contains at least n over four messages
thus we look at the product of those
things Omega N squared messages are sent
in this execution
so the number four we had a number four
so what so what we might be the
importance let's see okay so what we had
thing where it was crucial is we we had
to I had to piece and if we're 40 to be
small enough so that a process who's in
a bubble and not seeing anything else
happening the system looks like it's um
it's still a prize still up for an
appropriate execution okay if if if I
just if I I'm sending messages and
waiting to receive messages and things
like that from a process from other
processes and there were there only and
there fewer than n over four that I've
communicated with and the other ones
that are in bubbles then as far as I'm
concerned this is correct ik execution
okay the this is all fine it's just all
the other ones that happen to be good
processes I'm not communicating with
okay and so I still have to do something
because this is a valid execution so
that's where it comes in yes okay yeah
that's correct yeah I just was seeding
it in the simple form but yes you're
right okay other questions all right all
right now what I'd like to do - one is
the best you can do or even okay so the
previous results said with n over two
it's impossible
suppose I know
the number of aliases only another four
can end it I it depends on the number of
failures that have occurred and I think
there is some sort of a trade-off which
I don't remember offhand but since this
isn't my result thing I don't feel
obligated to remembered all the details
of that okay okay
so in distinguishability can be used in
other ways and nine but it can also be
used to get the lower bound of the
number of rounds to compute the denied
diameter of network okay so let's look
at this problem so every process knows
the size end of the network and the IDS
of its neighbors and each process is its
distinct ID and the in this particular
problem every process must have put the
diameter D of the network okay so that's
our goal
and again we're look at synchronous
message passing systems and each your
here we're going to look at synchronous
message passing systems and in each
round each process can send its send a
message of unlimited size to each of its
neighbors and we're not going to assume
any faults okay so this is a look at a
simple thing okay so the basin the
following results is full or and pretty
obvious but competing the diameter
requires a mega of the rounds
essentially though if we look at the
process over in the left and so in this
case in the first three rounds it can't
distinct I mean I'll have trouble
distinguishing between this this graph
and this graph in fewer than D minus two
rows okay so but that's not a very
interesting thing okay
now the upper bound can be achieved by
flooding the network so that every
network so that every node learns the
entire graph and that would take order
derails d rounds exactly or G minus one
rounds yeah I guess D rounds exactly
okay so um now let's turn so that wasn't
very interesting and the problem was is
because with flooding we're just sending
the whole graph and you know you have
the local information and then you just
send them what you know about the graph
and everybody learns everything so
there's nothing interesting
computationally there but let's suppose
that the size of each message is more
reasonable so let's suppose that each
process can send a message of B bits to
each of its neighbors in each round
where being typically B is going to be
ordering plug in okay so something small
and this is actually a very well studied
model it's called the congest model so
it actually has a name to it a
synchronous message passing each process
is a distinct ID and there no faults
okay so we're looking at that and we're
gonna look at the computing the diameter
problem okay so the following we get the
following theorem we check again it's a
fairly recent not that old any algorithm
terminating the diameter of graph with n
nodes using beep it messages requires a
mega Vanover be B rounds and in fact
this is true even if all nodes know in
advance that the diameter is either 2 or
3 okay so I mean certainly the lower
bound of D still a mega fee still holds
but even for graphs of very low dynamic
we get we get a good lower bound and it
would be okay so the approach is to use
a reduction from communication a
communication complexity problem and so
and this is basically what an OOP was
referring to I guess yesterday when he
gets to being morning when he was
talking about using communication
complexity for distributed computing
problems so I'm going to give one such
example because I even get to one
alright so in this particular case we're
going to look
at a reduction from the set destroyed
miss problem so this is one of the
standard hard problems so I just as
review Alice hat and Bob each have
inputs K bits of input and they want to
determine and these eight K bits are
deter are basically denoting the
characteristic vectors of a k elements
at R or a subset of K elements and they
want to they want to know if there two
sets are disjoint namely if for every
index I either X I is equal to 0 or Y is
equal to 0 so that's what we want to do
okay and as a new mentioned this problem
is hard from a communication complexity
point of view we need a mega of K bits
of communication to solve this problem
by any randomized protocol
okay so the idea here is to reduce the
set to straightness problem to the
problem of determining whether the
diameter of a certain graph has is
either 2 or 3 okay
so let's consider the following in node
graph it consists of two nodes here
these black ones and and / - / + 4
clicks each of size n over 2 n minus 2
over 4 so the remaining ones are divided
up like that okay and these the blue red
green and purple are sets of nodes or
kinks okay and so what we have is the
two black nodes are connected to one
another the left black node is connected
to all nodes and the blue and the green
fleex the black node of the right is
connected all of the red nodes and all
the purple notes and moreover the-- if
we look at the ice node in the blue
clique it's connected to the ice node
and the red click for fry equals one to
n over N minus 2 over 4 and similarly
for the between green and purple okay so
that's our that's our graph we're gonna
start with and what's the diameter this
graph okay well I claim it's three okay
so let's see why
well black nodes so that lets say this
laughs less black nodes connected here
and one distance one to any of those in
distance two to any of these okay and
similarly for the other black node so
now let's look at let's say some no not
in the blue klieg okay so it can reach
any node in the red plate in two hops
okay by just going to appropriate the
appropriate corresponding one then going
across and similarly can it can also
reach any node in the green clique in
two hops okay by going through the black
node okay the problem is between blue
and purple there we have three hops okay
we can either go this way or this way
but we have three hops in the distances
three okay everybody happy good
all right now suppose that we add an
extra edge between here and here okay
what does that do for us okay now
there's a path between this node here
and the purple node that corresponds to
that green node okay and moreover
there's a path from this green node to
the court the red node that corresponds
here okay so these paths of length two
so now instead of having this path of
length three in these specific cases we
have paths of length two okay there's
only if we have this edge over here okay
we have this path of length two between
those and the path of length two beauty
knows okay
so what we're gonna do is associate a
different variable X eye with each of
the possible edges between the blue and
green notes and there's since there's n
minus 2 over 4 nodes in the a and the
blue click and n minus 2 over 4 nodes
and the green click all together there
are this K and this the square of that
possible edges ok so here's one okay
between let's say the third note here
and the first note here okay
and we'll say that the graph the edge is
going to be in the graph if and only if
the very Alice's input variable X I is
equal to zero
okay something room this is how we're
given an instance of set disjointness
we're going to construct this graph in
which we have a an edge reach variable
that Alice has introduced to zero and
we're going to associate the variable Y
with the possible edges between the
corresponding red and purple notes ok so
so if this is the third one here going
to the first-tier third first third and
first okay we have this Y I and yet just
going to be in the graph if and only if
Y is equal to zero okay
okay um so there's gonna be a path of
length to between this node here and
that node here okay if X I is equal to 0
or Y is equal to 0 okay and otherwise it
will not be ok so the resulting graph is
gonna have diameter 2 if and only if for
every value of K for every possible pair
of blue and green nodes and in
corresponding pair of red and purple
nodes either X is equal to 0 or Y is is
equal to 0 and otherwise the graph is
gonna have to I am in there - sorry
ahead diameter 3 okay now okay suppose
there's an R round algorithm for
determining whether the diameter of any
graph in this in this class okay class
SI ammeter 2 or 3
ok now the algorithm is gonna
communicate most n times R times B bits
across this cut okay why because in each
round each ok so that how many inches
are there here there at over 2 inches
and we can send things either way ok so
altogether there are going to be n
messages going across these meshes has B
bits and altogether there are rounds so
we look at the algorithm total number of
bits communicated is n times R times B
and now what we have is okay we have our
situation here here we the set just
during this problem and we want to solve
that so Alison put x1 to XK Bob his
input y1 2 YK now Alice has enough
information to construct from her her
inputs to construct this half of the
graph okay and Bob has enough
information from his inputs to construct
this half of the graph and now what
Alice and Bob are going to do is
simulate the algorithm ok so we're each
round they're going to look at what
kinds of things any local communication
can be done locally by alice or locally
by bob and don't it doesn't have
they communicated but anything that has
to go across the Scott actually has to
be communicated so but how many bits are
or have to be communicated okay they
seem you like this if they communicate
it most n times R times B bits okay so
what does that tell us well we know that
the complexity of sulfate and and from
that they can tell whether the graph has
diameter 2 or 3 and hence whether the
the original inputs are disjoint or not
okay and so what this tells us is
because we know we need these two Omega
of K bits even in randomized for
randomized algorithms to solve set
disjointness we know that n times R
times B has to be an Omega of K okay
which is Omega N squared and the
diameter of the algorithm did that's our
diameter out for them must take our
rounds which is Omega then over me
questions
good okay
now um okay so what we've just shown is
that we've we need a make of n over B
rounds to compete exactly compute the
diameter of a denote a diamond if you
have an end node graph with deviant
messages and so this is approximation
factor one and using depth breadth first
search can simulate you knew depth
through breadth first search on the
network and you can easily get you can
easily compute the diameter to within a
factor of two using breadth first search
okay and that only and that it would
take can be done in ordered ordered
derails okay so the approximate if
you're doing approximation factors that
I mean this and over B now is no longer
relevant in 2012 there was a lower bound
that showed that if we're gonna get a
three half minus epsilon approximation
then we need d plus and over and over
beat divided by poly log n rounds and
only a couple of years ago there was an
algorithm which showed that the three
half is approximation what we can do it
with D plus a square root of n ok so
there's this exactly showed shows that
it's hard to tell between two and three
so doesn't each other it's hard to
approximate to 1.5 yeah yeah so
approximation factors are just the
multiplicative Jiabao for you either two
puffs i've just yeah 20 30 ah okay so
you want the same thing
so I mean this this is just anyhow
looking at some of this so even though
the I I guess I should mention that this
particularly result the and over B is
there's actually an algorithm that
matches that for exact when B is order
log in I mean for you it works for be
order log in I mean any smaller number
of things but it's unknown whether it's
tight would be is is much bigger but
also that there's some big gaps here
in terms of open problems in terms of a
trade-off between approximation factor
and the the actual number of rounds that
we need i just wanted to state some
interesting some interesting open
problems there were actually k kharon
sensor Hillel gave a really nice talk at
pods and invited to talk at pod C last
month and where she surveyed this in a
variety of other problems including
minimum vertex cover to decide detecting
weather graph contains triangles or for
cycles and looking like there's a
variety of those so that's available in
the Pazzi website if you're interested
talking about some of the other open
problems in this area and yeah okay so
other questions
okay I think I'm going to stop here and
then we will continue with shared memory
lower bounds two different techniques
after the break
[Applause]